Subban here thanks for how are you
comfortable you are you self-conscious
that your feet do not touch the ground
there dad look at this you look at her
she looks like a child that is like a
block or something I'll get your block I
need a block for takes pee yeah this is
how relaxed the show is now Andy just
performs small chores and tasks what did
he do before I want to thank you because
here he comes
yeah sorry it took me a little while to
get the carpet on it it's still too
short
yeah you were very nice you had me you
had me on your I was getting ready to do
a stand-up tour and you kindly let me
come on a show that you do a live show
and let me do some stand-up yeah and I
was backstage you were hilarious before
you even go out on stage you start your
show from backstage holding a microphone
and you were slaying the audience really
hilarious and you weren't even on stage
it was great it's really it was classy
I appreciate that yeah you and you you
slayed the audience you also did yoga
backstage which I haven't experienced
before
with no one's done that before no I
don't typically take care of that
business at home and you're like yeah
Nanuk yoga yeah he does it's not yoga
yeah really in all fairness it's not
yoga it's I didn't I was just called
touching your toes yeah I before I go
out and do anything I do like a Crouch I
just try and limber up a little bit and
you were you were just totally [ __ ]
on me the whole time
you got your microphone you went okay
you had you to say who I was cuz I'm so
surprised we're like our first guest is
doing a bunch of exercise which seemed
to have nothing to do with his act
it really isn't important for me to be
limber but I do it and do you do it
before you come out to talk to somebody
like me as well yeah you're such a high
octane person that I feel you got it you
know you got to be ready when this
whirling dervish